[Music]
let's move on to we talk to IKEA but we
have to talk about the biggest star in
all of Sweden you did a video about
PewDiePie I did yes in defense of his
racist Nazi Nazi bigoted anti-semitism
yeah and you were Swedish you defended
him I did I was probably the only Swede
and/or Jew who did I fully defended him
yeah absolutely no I just think it was
ridiculous because there are real Nazis
out there whenever they use the word
anti-semite of someone who isn't an
anti-semite they really devalue the word
so I can't use it against great
anti-semites which annoys me yeah so
let's pause for a second can you just
set up what PewDiePie did for so
PewDiePie went on to some page where you
can pay anyone $5 to pretty much do
anything and he started trying this
service out and he found some maybe
Indian guys maybe you don't know and
they would dance and hold up a sign with
which could read whatever you wanted to
read and so he wanted it to read death
to all Jews and they did and they got
fired and he got well pressured and lost
a lot of his sponsorship deals I suppose
and accused of anti-semitism yeah button
my feeling is that his generation for
them Hitler and the Holocaust is
basically like Satan was a hundred years
ago it was the embodiment of evil though
he just wanted to see if they would
actually perform an evil service for the
mere sum of five dollars and they did
and he was horrified his reaction was
horrified and I think that says it all
so he was trying to show his followers
that it wasn't a good thing yeah but
kind of funny because it is kind of fun
yeah and it's not super advanced comedy
it's not the comedy of subtlety but
there is some sort of falling on your
ass in there
yeah and I thought it was a bit harsh to
label him an anti-semite just for
basically doing consumer research
well that was the interesting thing to
me it's like this guy has no history of
anti-semitism as far as I can tell from
anything I've seen of him he has no
history of bigoted bigotry or prejudice
racism or anything he now does something
that's just a joke now you could argue
back and forth all day we get every
comic in here
of all time and go whether it was stupid
or whether there's some auntie whatever
or just a bad joke or any of that or in
poor taste but all of that one incident
especially relates to round a joke
doesn't mean you're a bigot no but the
rush to judgment I actually found more
interesting than the specific thing
itself this is not like when Kramer lost
his temper on stage no this is a you
know someone we might argue if it's good
comedy or not I personally don't really
get the younger generations YouTube
comedy with all their editing and jump
cuts yeah yeah I do I'm redoing this in
one cut you're right with that
everything I've got cameras here but
we're not jumping um no I'm fine with
that
and I think it's a quite nice setup yeah
but I also think that when you look at
the editing of the younger generation
even in the editing there's a language
taking shape with punchlines and pauses
and everything so if you don't I'm not
probably ever going to be able to get it
completely but if you grow up with it
there's comedy in there yeah what was
the reaction from the media in Sweden no
really
here it was bananas I mean who Wall
Street Journal wrote ridiculous no weird
what do you make an ad usual
passive-aggressive doesn't suit their
metal story so they just don't bother
yeah it's like whenever I break a taboo
silence is the most common answer yeah
there's the media talk about him at all
because it is kind of famous issue that
is very liberating really yes one of our
most successful Swedes in the last few
years right but now silence so you think
that even that then because he's had a
little bit of a political evolution I
think himself or that he's gotten a
little edgy or talking about self that
that's just going to push him out yes
and at least of the public consciousness
in Sweden and the mainstream media
bombing online he's as big as ever it's
not going to change yeah well that was
the irony the guy's got something like
50
five million YouTube subscribers Wall
Street Journal would kill for 1% of that
yes so it's only a benefit for them to
attack him because it's going to get
clicks absolutely behind the paywall as
well quite cynical if you ask me so how
do you think we push back against some
of this because this is this is what you
do right yeah I'm like this is what you
do you're here talking about this stuff
we we see that the the media is just
eating everybody that comes out and
starts coming against this stuff what do
you do well I speak up because that's
all I can do I wouldn't handle
responsibility as an elected official
well I think my experience power tends
to corrupt and me faster than most
people yeah but I speak up and I hope
that some people who have skill and
maybe a sense of responsibility and
intelligence will go into politics or
you know affect change in some other way
in private corporations whatever just
responsible people take that
responsibility now
Yass crime do you find that when we have
conversation like this and we're talking
about what what socialism is doing what
leftism is doing all that that people
then suddenly don't think you're a
liberal that that because I sense that
you're actually a liberal I have we can
go through all your politics if you want
yeah lay out a couple things that you
believe in you know we can talk about
abortion or death penalty whatever if
you want just fire up a couple you're
obviously Pro marijuana I suspect home
are law no gay marriage absolutely Pro
almost any type of well I'm I'm Pro gays
yeah marriage I'm not so sure yeah fair
enough I can respect that and abortion
well that is a tough question isn't it
I'm from Sweden so abortion is nothing
to us it's a known question it's not a
taboo in any way shape or form and as a
libertarian I would say I would have to
go for the full autonomy in principled
argument that is a woman has the right
to abort to see this up until nine
months yeah but then again because as
long as I don't see proof of a soul I
can't expect humans to have a soul which
would be a religious argument for you
know preserving human life but in
practice
I think I would refer to science so if
they say we can save someone from this
amount of weeks then okay then that's
the limit right what else is a death
penalty well I'm against death penalty
mainly because of hypocrisy I don't
think a government can tell its citizen
to not kill people and then kill people
themselves so it has to be life in
prison or something as a as an
alternative to write that what do you
think would be like a fair tax system
you guys are taxed very high and we've
already discussed why did some inherent
probably enjoy adding some some reasons
that it's been good over time well it
probably well the entire system in
Sweden is built around you having an
employment to steady employment if you
have that then you're in it's perfect
it's fine you'll make a decent amount of
money you'll have five weeks paid
vacation you'll have medical everything
but in the recent years and I don't
think it has to do with immigration I
just think that a socialist system
eventually always eats itself as you
said so it the level of material wealth
has gone down dramatically in the last
30 years and immigration plays it plays
a part as well yeah but as a well I'm
and I'm a one-man company right as a
comedian so I pay a marginal tax of 75
percent which is quite a lot yeah so
relation anyway that means that sounds
insane well what that means is I I'm
supposed to play like maybe fifty five
percent and then I have 100 Kroners left
and I go into a store and I buy coffee
and then there's 20 I 28% v80
value-added tax yeah and there's some
other tax and in the end it's between
seventy and seventy five percent which
makes it almost impossible to live and
if you're like me or you're approaching
40 but you don't have children so you
don't really need all day care systems
and and you're not old and you're not
using hospitals very much then you're
just paying a shitload of money for
nothing basically because we don't have
an army we used to have a lot of sick
beds per cat hospital beds per capita in
the hospitals now I think we have
the fewest in the OECD really yeah so
that because the services got cut back
or they're more I think money is going
somewhere else I'm not entirely sure
where maybe Gender Studies and and we
have no army because the United States
have been paying for our defense for the
last sixty years so I think there are
certain things that we need to deal with
as a society that I don't really see
anyone bringing to the table in any
discussion or debate
yeah so right so now that you've laid
out some basic liberal stuff there yeah
but all yes but also I should say that I
mean the political scale here and in
Sweden is skewed I mean here if someone
yells at you liberal they're usually a
Republican or conservative right but in
Sweden if someone yells at me they're
socialist
they're like you're a liberal and that's
a bad word for them right well it's a
bit when the Conservatives failable they
mean it it's a bad word to I've been
trying to save the word I don't know
yeah I know but that's also fascinating
with a political skid because here it
goes from left to right and libertarian
would be almost as far right as you can
come yeah but I see myself in Europe as
in the middle of the plate the
left-right skin but very high up on
freedom yeah and our political scale is
more like a square divided up into
quadrants so you have well your opposite
me so left right and then freedom
authoritarian so I'm in the middle up
here really well that's why I've been
trying to explain to people that there's
so many commonalities between real
liberalism classical liberalism and
libertarianism because if we can get
these people to come together on the
basis of rights of individuality and
right there's a real movement there and
like how we made this yeah yeah exactly
and it may take many generations for it
to take root in a place like Sweden yes
because we never really had it yeah we
just had the idea of it and we call
ourselves ourselves of democracy and as
long as it was an extremely homogeneous
population I don't think the Swedes
really noticed that they voted for the
same part a year after year after year
yeah but after 30 years of the very
large immigration
differences come to light and by now I
think they're very confused
yeah so weird in 20 years as the the
immigrant population grows we know that
they generally reproduce more they're
taking more from the state than they're
giving partially it's not even their
fault as we've already discussed you
have the the older society getting older
or the original society getting older
these things they're just going to keep
getting worse yes yes unless of course
Russian they just yeah and then
everything would be all right
nah then it would be even worse but you
know at least we like we should not
blame the failure of the socialist
system anymore yeah
so it's interesting so you do have a
sort of fatalistic view of this because
as you said earlier when you go you want
to be able to say well I told you so
yeah and it's sort of like you don't see
a correction for this that's sort of on
the horizon I see a small correction but
I think as I said it's too little too
late and I mean we teach our school
children about what political ideologies
but of course there's a lot of Marx and
Foucault in there and there's no Mill
whatsoever you know how will they be
able to understand what Liberty means
they they don't Swedes don't understand
that yeah I usually say that if
Americans national myth is freedom
Swedes are safety and Swedes will
sacrifice almost everything for safety
and you know the old libertarian a dodj
even though it might be misquoted or
quoted out of context that if you
sacrifice one for the other you will end
up with neither yeah yes where do you
think Trump falls into the next day what
are the people of Sweden think of Trump
or the state of America we will think of
Trump whatever huff posts right yeah but
I think that Trump is a very interesting
trickster character and I think that
because I don't see him as a Republican
at all yeah nor do I see him as a
liberal I see him as pretty much a
narcissistic guy who's a bit erratic and
this could go either way yeah yeah well
I mean that's basically what I've
he's certainly not a he's not a
traditional Republican he's not he's not
a conservative it's a different thing
all together and I think right before we
started the cameras
I said you it feels like the chessboard
has just been thrown up the pieces are
everywhere now we don't know which way
it's going to go for me though i tarde
for me to just get everyone so outraged
constantly I just don't want to keep
adding to the web saying outrage well I
think that is unavoidable because if you
voice your opinions then a lot of
leftists leftists at least in this place
sometime will be upset with you yeah
because they don't want to come out of
their insolence and bubble but I think
that because Swedish papers they say
that he has the lowest approval rating
of any American president and that is a
pure lie I went into the Pew Research
and he actually has an almost
phenomenally high approval rating within
the Republican Republican voting the
Republican voters so it's exceptionally
high and the way I see it from the
outside the people who voted for Trump
they are tired of the your Parliament or
Senate and Congress being locked in this
unending really status quo and they just
wanted to throw a brick through the
window to see what happens and I think
by now we know what happens it doesn't
change the internal politics of the
United States very much but it does have
a slight effect on the world
yeah yes right so do you think that well
I guess although you said it's whatever
Huffington Post says what do you think
keep the average person in Sweden do you
think they're looking at the United
States gone
it may be irreparably different than it
was before whatever the nature of our
relationship you know when Trump says
we're going to charge Japan for
protecting them and whatever we're gonna
do with NATO and all that's up does that
make people in Sweden go oh yeah well so
certain that extent I think it does and
and most people don't know that we have
paid back to America and Snowden let us
know that we have paid the NSA with a
lot of information so basically our NSA
is a local office of your NSA in
Scandinavia so
um yeah I'd preach them out and I think
by now every politician in Europe knows
that they have to contribute more to
Western Europe's defense yeah so on the
broader free speech part of this you're
here in America right now you mentioned
your cousin's in American community and
you're going to do stand-up tonight at
the or tomorrow night at the Comedy
Store when you see that the pieces of
free speech that we seem to be losing
right now yeah and that we're kind of
doing it to our say it's not our
government doing it to us at least now
it could be in the future but I don't
really see it as the government doing it
I see it as us doing it to ourselves I
see it as college kids silencing people
and now administration's and all that
you must be incredibly depressing as an
outsider see that it is because you were
when it came to free speech a beacon and
I come from a country where we don't
really have free speech we have it on
paper sort of but you can't insult
people so it's not really free speech
yeah and if you try to use you free
speech in Sweden you'll be ostracized if
you voice an opinion that is different
from the mainstream opinion so Swedes
don't really understand the concept as I
said of Liberty so how can they
understand free speech so what would
happen so if you were to really insult
somebody forget okay so we've had the
authorization that's just what we're
doing well that's what society is doing
to you but what where's the legal line
there I think in theory I could be I
could be sued by the aggrieved party
yeah but in practice that rarely happens
because as I said Swedes are very afraid
of conflict right so they will just give
you the silent treatment so they'll be
offended but they're not offended enough
to actually publicly make an issue out
of it in a weird way there's probably
some decency in that shame as opposed to
us where we get into legal battles over
maybe maybe maybe or you could view it
like this that the social mechanism of
shame is actually more powerful than the
legal system of shame shaming people
because going to prison or being ordered
to pay a fine I mean that's a sort of
way for society to make you feel shame
what you're done right
but if society is already taking care of
that by giving you the silent treatment
and not inviting you to parties them yes
you already have an excellent system in
place have you been able to get a couple
other like if there are some Swedish
comedians out there are are they I mean
I would imagine that's probably the only
place where this is happening if it's
not really happening at the political
level you mentioned the Democratic
Socialist but like is there something
happening comedy-wise that's getting
people talk about this well I am but
apart from that not really I think if
you ask a Swede where they stand
politically they will like a knee-jerk
reaction say leftist even though most
comedians really are libertarians if the
I mean because you know they enjoy
freedom they obviously can handle the
chaos and so on and so on but they're
just raised into it because when the
Social Democratic Party really got their
grip on power they exterminated the
Swedish state church so they basically
killed God and replaced him with the
Social Democratic Party and that's why
for most Swedes social democracy is more
of a religion than an actual political
philosophy so I feel that the way to
although I think I got your answer it's
been a through-line
to all this but I feel like the final
question I should be asking you is if we
had to look at Sweden if you had a
crystal ball and you're looking 20 years
from now yes it's not your deathbed yet
hopefully hopefully but it's 20 years
from now and you're looking at as to
what happened to Sweden where do you
think we're at in 20 years
well I hope I'm hoping for a
liberalization of Sweden but I'm I'm not
very convinced it will happen hopefully
if nothing else marijuana will be legal
so that is that the one hope to at least
deal with all this other nuts yeah it's
some consolation yeah yes okay so
hopefully marijuana is legal but beyond
that I mean really these I sent you're
you're sort of I don't think this is in
an odd way but but not hopeful that I
think the system is going to crack
itself anyway sooner or later the
immigration issue is just basically
hurrying it along
so they're going to have to that I mean
the big liberalization of our health
care markets and school market or
schools that have happened didn't happen
because oh this is a good idea we should
do this it happened because we had to
because our system wasn't working it was
costing too much we couldn't afford it
do you think Europe's even paying
attention enough to this like would you
want to go there and just start shaking
people and go guys
that's pretty much what I'm trying to do
but verbally yeah because I don't really
like physical contact that much yeah a
little bit some a dismantle work to go
there and physically yeah as everybody
but do you think they're looking at this
as a marker do you think that that
starting to take root I hope so yeah I
to a certain extent I can I can feel the
winds changing or something but to what
I don't know and as I said America has
Liberty in its foundation there's a
cultural understanding of what it means
to take personal responsibility here
there's no such thing in Sweden so
Sweden I have very little hope for but
when it comes to the rest of Western
Europe maybe a tad bit more hope most
free England yeah alright well here's
what we're gonna do we're going to wrap
up now I am going to do your podcast but
I'm thinking that maybe we should take a
drive at some point you're here for a
little bit and we could do it like in
the world's largest IKEA would that be
absolutely you know maybe we'll just
find a nice Shea's lounge and a little
side thing and there's so many people
there nobody'll know what's going on
yeah or we could do it in like you know
I'll 62 bin 8 just see what's there
why not well I like to believe bucola
which is well aware that bookshelves so
that the books yeah yeah we're like all
these words they always sound like they
sound like oddly sexual things that that
Rose would have said from saying all up
in the Golden Girls
all right most of them are just names
they're just names yeah common names
like Greta or pasta yeah yeah all right
I want to go to your make you more than
well yeah if I come to Sweden you'll
take me to an Ikea
can I go and take you to every no not
every idea that would be silly but yeah
I'll take you to an Ikea let me take it
alright maniac that's been listed by the
axe my absolutely would yeah you know I
can't afford to say no to new friends
fair enough all right well it's been a
pleasure chatting with you and for more
on Aaron although he doesn't like being
called a youtuber he is on the YouTube
check them out youtube.com slash the
Aaron flat
[Music]
you